a New York advice columnist accuses
President Trump of raping her 23 years
ago in a dressing room at Bergdorf
Goodman she just seemed to remember this
now and is using the accusation to sell
a book we will analyze whether the
claims are credible then new documents
show that Ilhan Omar almost certainly
committed immigration fraud and possibly
did so with her brother gross finally
pedophilia goes mainstream and mayor
Pete loses his luster in South Bend all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael and old show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a crazy lady is accusing Trump of raping
her 23 years ago there's no other way to
describe it I this isn't to say that
there's a 0% chance that the claims are
true we'll we'll analyse we'll go
through exactly what she said happened
and how she's defending it in Trump's
response as well but it is certainly the
case that she is a crazy lady it's also
a little curious timing she's got this
book out on feminism and men and only
now only as she's going on this book
tour has she remembered this event that
occurred allegedly 23 years ago she
didn't remember it
during the last two or three years from
president Trump was the most famous
person on the face of the planet but now
she has remembered it now everyone is
taking it SuperDuper seriously and we
will we will examine what that means for
the culture broadly
I shouldn't say everyone is taking it
super seriously the mainstream media are
taking it seriously they're trying to
push this story but I think people who
are on Twitter people who were just
reading this people who are just voters
going about their regular lives I don't
think any of them are taking this
seriously because the left has so
weaponized sexual assault allegations
that at this point the the bar of
credulity is is very high it's very
difficult to convince someone this
actually happened this is bad news for
people who actually have survived sexual
assaults and rapes but that's part of
the left's plan so what are they saying
happened this woman a Jean Carol was an
advice columnist for Elle for has been
an advice columnist rail for 26 years
she now has a book out what do we need
men for a Modest Proposal tells you a
little bit about where she's coming from
and she has this one chapter that she's
sent to New York magazine which is
called hideous men and the hideous men
details all of these men that she hates
the last of whom is Donald Trump so one
of the previewed sections she sent to
New York magazine it begins with this
line
when I entered Indiana University I was
the most boy-crazy 17 year old in the
nation so she's setting up this idea she
was boy crazy she would go out with all
these boys every day she was going out
with one boy or two boys
and now all these years later she hates
men she wants to get rid of men she no
longer sleeps with men and she says in
one of these instances that she was in
Bergdorf Goodman very expensive store in
New York and the scene is a little weird
but she's sort of flirting with Trump
and they're joking about lingerie and
she brings Trump into a dressing room
and she she tells Trump to try on
lingerie for her or something and then
he grabs her and he makes a move for
when he's groping her and he's kissing
her and then she leaves and that's it
and allegedly at some point she's a
little a little unclear on the details
but at some point she says she was
almost raped or or actually raped or but
it didn't last very long
okay is her claim credible you can read
the chapter of her book that she
released on New York Magazine you can
read some of the coverage of it you
should form your own conclusion on this
she did an interview on CNN listen for
yourself what do you want to say to
Donald Trump that terrifies me that she
said that that is that is at the thought
of confronting him
no I you know you just stunned me by
saying that it terrifies me although I I
think I could I think yeah I think that
you could confront him now I mean what
part scares Oh will you go with me
Allison seriously
no no listen that is a that is a
terrible situation even a question it
just terrifies me look at me I can
hardly talk now that she said that what
part what part terrifies you well it
puts it reveals to me what I'm in the
middle of doing is what it does that's
you've made it very clear what I'm in
the midst of doing okay so this woman is
obviously a lunatic and I don't even
mean that to make fun of her or anything
like that she's clearly not well she's
either on drugs or she's mentally
unstable she is not speaking like
someone who is in charge of her senses
she's got
long pauses she's saying bizarre lines
she's not answering questions she's not
talking about the incident itself so
she's certainly a lunatic now that
doesn't mean that it didn't happen that
is the other side of it so to give her
her due doesn't mean it doesn't didn't
happen we'll go through a couple more
moments in this interview and we'll have
to come to our conclusion but first
let's talk about finding freelance
talent for your business or project
finding the right freelancer can be
time-consuming frustrating overwhelming
to manage where do you go to find the
talent even if you're in a city like LA
or New York
everybody's a freelancer you could throw
a rock and you hit a freelancer but how
do you actually find them how do you
know that they'll be able to deliver
thanks to Fiverr pro finding the right
freelancer doesn't have to be a struggle
Fiverr pros marketplace connects
businesses with hand vetted freelancers
with who offer hundreds of digital
services including graphic design
copywriting web programming film editing
and more you can find almost anything on
Fiverr you can search by service
delivery time price reviews and more
you'll know exactly what you're paying
for upfront there's no negotiating going
on you just get the price right there no
transaction is complete until you are
100% satisfied with the work that you
receive I love Fiverr I use Fiverr for
years especially when I was working
campaigns in New York when I was I was
working campaigns I was working in the
theater and sometimes you need some
graphic design sometimes you need a
little freelance service it's so simple
it saves you time time is money and if I
I would use Fiverr again and again
Fiverr sellers have worked with some of
the most influential brands in the world
you're guaranteed to receive VIP
customer support find freelance services
you can trust customer service you can
count on don't don't risk the projects
you need you will get results you can be
proud of all on one platform take five
and check out fiber comm FIV er R two
R's dot-com and you will receive 10% off
your first order by using my code
Knowles Canada wles very easy don't
waste any more time get the service you
need I can tell you I have had
tremendously good experiences on Fiverr
go to fiverr.com fiv er are.com code
knowles fiverr.com
NOLs check it out so this woman is not
well write it it's really a shame that
people are even putting her on
television it seems exploitative now did
it happen that's the question there's no
evidence that this woman knows Donald
Trump or that Donald Trump knows her
except for one photo that she puts in
the magazine article there's a photo of
Donald Trump from behind but it looks
like Trump you can tell from the hair
and they're at some sort of black-tie
gala and it's in the lobby of a building
because you can see the revolving door
and it looks as though Trump is talking
to her husband at the time and her again
who knows if you're in public life you
go to events like this all the time you
meet hundreds of people at these events
you take hundreds of photos at every one
of these events you will meet people for
10 seconds they'll take a photo 99.9999%
of the time you will never see that
person again I was just you know I was
at a conference giving a speech on
Friday up in Santa Barbara I probably
took 100 or 200 pictures there I don't
know all of those people I don't
probably never talked to a lot of them
again same tie was at another event last
night Donald Trump has been doing these
for 40 years so you see one photo it
doesn't really tell you a whole lot so
let's let her in her own words describe
what happened and then you can decide if
this is credible and you thought when
you included those 11 pages in the book
that it wouldn't get this amount of
tension why it was only one of 21
hideous men you know we didn't but it is
the President of the United States you
didn't know the onslaught that you would
be in the middle of right now I mean you
are talking about the president the
United States and you are accusing him
of sexual assault yeah and you've gone
there it's part of the culture it's part
of the hideous men thing benefit men
have ruled they have run things as you
know for the last 20,000 years I'm sick
of it it's just time that when they get
to run things okay there's no way she's
telling the truth right when you hear
this she's asked what
happened tell me what happened with
Donald Trump you're accusing Trump of
sexual assault and she tries to evade it
first of all she just kind of nods
blankly and won't answer the question so
Alison Cammarata has to keep asking you
accused the president and what is her
answer does she say damn right I accused
the president that man is a horrible
rapist and he should be in prison
no she actually kind of defends him
because all he's just one of the men
yeah there are a lot of hideous men so
if this guy raped to you which is the
claim why aren't you going after him
why aren't you given all the details you
can why aren't you demanding justice why
are you defending him well it's because
she's selling a book which is called why
who needs men why do we need men
something like that and she's selling
this chapter hideous men and nobody
would read the book and nobody would
read the chapter and no one would care
at all except that she mentioned Donald
Trump so she includes Trump in there is
almost a footnote and now everyone's
talking about it but she clearly doesn't
want to keep talking about and then you
see at the end she goes look it's just
it's the part of this hideous men thing
what is the hideous men thing that's
your term I don't know what the hideous
men thing is this is your ideological
construct this is like what happens when
you see this time and time again there's
a police shooting they say this is
evidence of racism then you find out the
cop was black then you find out the guy
the perpetrator had a gun then you find
out it wasn't in evidence of racial
bigotry and they say well okay this
example wasn't true but it gets to a
greater truth that's that's what we're
seeing here because she's being asked
what happened in this rape what did he
rape you are you pursuing this she goes
well yeah I mean but it's not just Trump
forget about Trump stop please stop
asking about Trump it's part of the
broader truth it's part of the hideous
men thing women have been oppressed for
tens of thousands of years men have been
running things and now women need to run
things say wait what are we talking
about they're running things why are we
talking about the patriarchy what we're
actually talking about rape she doesn't
want to talk about that she wants to
talk about her ideology why because
there's no evidence that this
actual example actually happened but
then even if that isn't enough she is
asked point-blank will you pursue this
as a criminal matter
once you're done selling books once
you're done getting New York magazine to
publish your chapter or whatever will
you actually pursue this as a criminal
matter you know where there will be an
investigation where there will be
evidence where if you make a false
allegation you look really bad it may
may even be criminal here's what she
says are you prepared to keep fighting
this to tell your story yes
that's what I'm doing that's exactly
what I'm doing it's the only way to
change things it's the only way we have
to hold him accountable not only him but
a lot of a lot of guys and do you think
that by pursuing an actual legitimate
case through the New York City police
because the mayor has said that because
the statute of limitations has changed
do you think that that could help
further your secret I'm considerate but
as far as I know it the limitations have
there run out as far as I know but you
would consider it I'd consider it
there it is she gives up the whole game
Alyson Camerata kudos Dallas in
Cammarata for at least asking sort of
serious questions she says look mayor de
Blasio says the law is changed you can
pursue this case as a criminal matter
will you do that she says well I don't I
don't know I I don't know about that I
mean I would consider it but I I don't
intend to do it and far as I know you
can't pursue it as a criminal matter
she's really pushing back on this saying
no no no I can't I can't have to
actually prove what I'm saying no no I'm
pretty sure I don't because she wrote
the book assuming she would never have
to prove it she published the chapter
assuming she would never have to prove
it now Allison Cameron is saying no no
you can don't worry we can pursue this
as a criminal matter she says no why I
would I would consider it and you see
there again she she defends Trump she
says and it's not just Trump it's other
guys we got a hold Trump accountable but
it's really bigger we have to hold
everybody accountable
if the President of the United States
raped you in a dressing room at Bergdorf
Goodman and you somehow just forgot
about this for 23 years and then two and
a half years into his presidency you
decide now you're gonna start pursuing
it and you are told that he can be held
criminally liable if this accusation is
true then you pursue it as a criminal
matter if it's not true you answer like
she answered just there never gets into
specifics about Trump keeps trying to
deflect says she doesn't want to pursue
the case I'll consider it I'll consider
it but I'm pretty sure it's not true no
it is you you can you can pursue this as
a criminal matter is what Allison
cammarata is saying because I'm pretty
sure you can't please don't hold me to
this please don't because now the next
part of this story if it is the case
that she can pursue this as a criminal
matter will be the obvious question why
isn't she going to do it there was that
woman who all the statutes of
limitations had run out on Bill Cosby
there was one woman who fell within the
statute of limitations she pursued legal
action and now Bill Cosby's in prison so
if this were true if this allegation
were true presumably this woman could do
exactly the same thing and then Trump
goes to jail except it's not true except
there's no evidence that it's true
what do we conclude from this I suspect
that this woman is a crazy person I
think we all can assume she's a crazy
person I also think she's a bit of a
victim here I think she's a victim of
her publisher and I think she's a victim
of CNN she writes this book she's some
longtime feminist writes a book about
how she hates women
or hates men rather and things women
should control the whole world and her
publisher needs to sell books so
probably they're gonna try to spice up
the book a little bit you get this Trump
allegation in there then they need to
sell the books immediately so they start
pimping her out to New York magazine New
York magazine which has very little
journalistic integrity decides they're
gonna run this allegation without any
corroboration whatsoever then she brings
this to CNN CNN brings her on television
this is clearly not a well woman and
they are exploiting her there's
winning her to get Donald Trump because
the story is too good they don't check
any of the facts they don't have any
evidence we'll get to president Trump's
response which was typically blunt and
direct but first speaking of safety
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer now you already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
and you know about them because I tell
you about them because they're super
cool they make you feel safe and they
make you feel like you're living in the
future ring helps you stay connected to
your home anywhere in the world so if
you are waiting on a package delivery or
you are waiting on people who some
guests are gonna show up or you've got
some burglar about to show up or your
mother-in-law is about to show up and I
don't necessarily know which one is
better you will get an alert and you
will be able to see here and speak to
them all from your phone that is thanks
to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices so we at the
Daily wire love ring I give it out to
all my friends as housewarming gifts
senior producer Jonathan hey a couple
months ago he's sleeping in his bed at 3
o'clock in the morning what happens he
gets an alert on his phone he could have
gotten that alert if he was at the
office or if he was on a beach in Hawaii
somewhere he gets the alert and it's
he's too drugged out wackos trying to
case the joint trying to get into his
house so he says hey what do you want he
sees them he can talk to them they say
oh oh uh nothing in this scamper away
because they know that that guy's home
it can just don't be a victim make
yourself feel safe make your family feel
safe as a listener you will get a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home home security
used to be really complicated used to be
there was the neighborhood watch used to
be all these expensive crazy machines
and systems this is the first home
security system that I have felt is
sleek cool perfect simple an incredible
value it's it's just the best ones the
first one that I've ever been attracted
to and it really does make me feel safe
just go to ring.com slash anoles kano
wles ring.com
slash Knowles canna wles so how does
President Trump respond
to these allegations typical Trumpy way
doesn't mess around doesn't beat around
the bush he cuts right to the point he
said quote shame on those who make up
false stories of assault to get
publicity for themselves or sell a book
or carry out a political agenda like
Julie sweat Nick who falsely accused
justice Brett Kavanaugh it's just as bad
for people to believe it particularly
when there is zero evidence worse still
for a dying publication to try to prop
itself up by peddling fake news it's an
epidemic false accusations diminish the
severity of a real assault all should
condemn false accusations and any actual
assault in the strongest possible terms
and then he said at the end of the
statement if anyone has information that
the Democratic Party is working with MS
Carroll or New York magazine please
notify us as soon as possible the world
should know what's really going on it is
a disgrace and people should pay dearly
for such false accusations everything he
said there is absolutely correct and as
often happens and I know we there's this
idea out there that Donald Trump is the
least moral man that's ever walked the
earth because he's had very public moral
failings throughout his career this
statement shows total moral clarity
false accusations especially of crimes
as serious as rape are awful they're
despicable
they are the accusers should be ashamed
of themselves
the journalistic outlets quote unquote
that peddle them should be ashamed of
themselves the people who believe them
should be ashamed of themselves who
believe them without evidence we have to
make this perfectly clear there is no
evidence whatsoever the President Trump
did this the only reason that we think
that this is even possible to have
happened at all is because this woman
said it happened and this is what's
behind the left's agenda of believe all
women hear this believe all women as
though having two x-chromosomes
automatically means you can't lie you're
biologically incapable of lying if
you're a woman if you have one of those
Y chromosomes mmm then you got to have
investigations then you need to show
evidence but women women can't lie also
men can be women Oh
so gender is a social construct also
there's no such thing as biological sex
but I'm sorry though those are other
leftist premises we have to put those
aside for now because on this particular
tactic you have to believe all women why
women lie all the time
there have been rape hoaxes all the time
some of the biggest rape stories in the
country over the last ten years turned
out to be completely fictitious that
story at UVA that Rolling Stone super
serious journalistic outlet ran of a
girl being gang-raped at UVA completely
made-up
she was proven to be a complete liar
about Duke lacrosse this was the first
major rape case in the last 20 years the
first major campus rape case that we
were talking about forever and ever a
stripper said that she was raped by the
Duke lacrosse team totally false she
completely made it up proven to have
made it up ruin those kids lives but
completely made it up
al Sharpton got his career because he
championed Tawana Brawley who said she
had been raped by a white guy guess what
happened totally made up a total lie
the left never apologizes for it al
Sharpton never apologizes for it there
are false accusations
would that we could believe all women I
would love it if we could believe every
woman who said that she had been raped
rape is a horrible crime if we could
believe all want women it would make it
a lot easier to prevent it to stop it to
get justice for the people who
perpetrated but we can't because there
are constantly false rape allegations
often peddled by the media so you can't
believe all women why does the left want
us to believe all women because this is
a tool that they use anytime they don't
like a guy there in 1991 at the
confirmation of Clarence Thomas
he's a excellent candidate he's got an
impeccable legal background he's a
totally upright guy they can't stop
Clarence Thomas the most originalist
justice probably ever on the Supreme
Court so what do they do they make up a
sexual harassment claim against him and
they bring a Nita Hill over and now they
turn to need a hill into a saint and
Anita Hills testimony totally collapses
does not hold up to scrutiny
there's no
that he did any of those things and now
he's tarnished his reputation is still
tarnished they still think of him as
some sort of sexual predator Brett
Kavanaugh zero evidence that this guy
ever assaulted women was improper this
guy lived one of the squeakiest cleanest
lives probably in politics federal judge
for 12 years never a peep about this on
one of the most important courts in the
country on the DC Circuit never a peep
but then President Trump nominates him
for the Supreme Court and all of a
sudden well now he's a rapist because
it's so heinous and because the left has
set up this this culture where you have
to believe all women you take an
accusation as evidence itself an
accusation is not evidence an accusation
is an accusation
then you need evidence to justify them
and you see that happening here as well
this is a major problem George will a
number of years ago came out and he said
this culture of just automatically
believing accusations on campuses now
depriving the accused of their due
process rights so students who were
accused of rape or sexual assault that
matter isn't handled by the criminal
justice system in virtually 100% of
cases in virtually 100% of cases it's
handled by kangaroo courts of professors
and Dean's and administrators and
bureaucrats who have absolutely no right
to be handling them no expertise in
handling these cases and they deprive
the accused of due process that's not
how it's supposed to work in the United
States when George Will pointed out that
this was unjust pointed out that
oppression and victimhood carries
currency these days which is encouraging
this sort of behavior he was accused by
Elizabeth Warren among other senators of
not taking rape and sexual assault
seriously and what George will said was
what we should all say when we point out
that you need evidence to back up an
allegation he said on the contrary
senators I think I take rape and sexual
assault much more seriously than you do
New York magazine thinks because they
run some totally baseless allegations
from 23 years ago that's just coming up
now just
coincidentally it cooked coincidentally
while this woman is trying to sell a
book they think that they're taking
sexual assault seriously they're getting
it out in the open they're airing this
news CN n taking it very seriously
you're not when you air these totally
baseless allegations without any
evidence you were doing exactly the
opposite you were damaging the
credibility of every other woman who has
been sexually assaulted or raped you are
making it much much harder to believe
them because of hoaxes because of
cynical people because of people trying
to peddle books without any evidence
whatsoever shame on them shame on CN n
shame on this woman shame on the people
who are believing this without any
evidence speaking of false claims in
politics Ilhan Omar's story on her
strange marriages is falling apart
looks like she almost certainly
committed immigration fraud and she
might have done it with her brother
which is very very gross we will examine
the new evidence that has come to light
and will it will interview Ilan Omar to
see what she thinks about this well at
least interview her as much as any other
outlet has been able to interview her
which is absolutely not at all I think
my next book is going to be Ilhan Omar's
defense against the charges that she
committed immigration fraud a
comprehensive guide we'll get to all of
that and a whole lot more but first I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and B
YouTube go over to daily wire.com ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the end
reclaim ensure you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get them out wall show you get
to ask questions in the mailbag you get
another Kingdom you get test questions
backstage you get everything you get
everything and the leftist tears tumblr
that sounds like oh yeah that sounds
like a rising store Democratic
congresswoman commits immigration fraud
that tastes like Pete Buddha judge is
being called racist by Democrats and by
his own constituents and that sounds mmm
that just tastes so so good make sure
you get yours so you can drink them up
go to daily wire comm we'll be back with
a lot more
Ilhan Omar probably married her brother
she at least almost certainly committed
immigration fraud but she also probably
married her brother this rumor has been
going around for a couple years now in
the mainstream media will not pick it up
they won't run with it it's only
conservative media who had been saying
this woman's got a weird marital history
it looks like she had a sham marriage it
looks like she did it to game us
immigration policy looks like the guy
might have been her brother the
mainstream media wouldn't look into it
wouldn't look into the evidence now
we've got serious reports out that she
did at new legal documents uncovered
show the timeline this is all very
confusing as or most things that Ilhan
omar is involved in here's the timeline
2002 Ilhan Omar married a guy named
Achmed here see in a religious ceremony
not a legal ceremony they were not
legally married but religiously they
were six years later 2008 Omar and here
see allegedly quote decided to end our
relationship in our faith tradition this
raises a question they were married for
six years religiously but not married
legally why not what were they doing for
six years and then if the relationships
ours they decide to end their
relationship okay I guess it's
convenient that they were never legally
married early in 2009 Omar then legally
marries a guy named Achmed nor Syed el
me so she has never been married before
legally so that's not a big deal it's a
little fast though she ends her
relationship with her husband or at
least according to religious tradition
husband of six years and then
immediately gets married to this guy
Achmed noir Saeed l me stranger things
have happened but the timing is a little
weird
two years later Omar and L me
religiously divorce now not legally
divorced they're still legally married
but they religiously divorce and that
same year Omar and heresee reconcile so
Omar and here C are married religiously
for six years
then they break up and Omar immediately
legally marries another guy for two
years then religiously separates from
the other guy and immediately reconciles
with her religious husband of six years
and they get back together okay
a little strange then in 2017 so six
years later Omar and L me legally
divorce so they've been legally married
for eight years even though they've only
ostensibly been together for two years
and she's been with this other guy for
all but two years of that since 2002
then in 2018 one year after she legally
divorces Elmi she legally marries her
see who she was religiously married to
for six years then split for a couple
years then we got back together with for
another six or seven years okay little
strange so that that was what we already
knew and the mainstream media wouldn't
report on it because they like Ilhan
Omar so much and if you ever questioned
anything she does you're accused of
racism and xenophobia and Islamophobia
whatever legal documents now show that
Omar was living with her see her first
husband in 2009 that's a year after she
says that they split up and that was the
same year that she married l me and that
was two years before she says she
reconciled with her C so now nothing
about either of these timelines makes
sense it gets even worse Omar and her
see the first husband
the real husband then probably not her
brother husband also filed joint taxes
together in 2014 and 2015
so are Marne her see this is wrong in
bizarre for two reasons one they were
supposed to be broken up they were they
were Omar and her C were not legally
married at this time and you're not
supposed to file joint taxes if you're
not legally married but at the same time
Omar was legally married to L me so if
she's gonna file joint taxes with
anybody it should be with L me l me you
think might be a little upset that his
wife is filing joint taxes with another
man ostensibly her ex-husband
and her future husband her ex ex-husband
then it gets even worse somehow under
penalty of perjury during divorce
proceedings Ilhan omar said that she had
not contacted or known the whereabouts
of Elmi since the summer of 2011 because
the courts are looking for ell me they
said way to say we some doesn't sit
right here we've got to make sure that
this divorce is legitimate that these
this marriage was legitimate in the
first place that it wasn't just a sham
because these sort of sham marriages
happen all the time to gain the
immigration system so she says she had
she hadn't seen el me she didn't know
his whereabouts since 2011 but photos on
social media show they did see each
other he saw and now Ilhan Omar's
daughters are all by the other guy the
real husband then not the brother photos
on social media show he was around he
saw that this guy el me was around so
the kids saw Ilhan Omar well after the
time that she says was the last time she
saw him she lied we know she lied it has
been proven that she lied about very
important questions she lied about
criminal activity that she did she at
least filed taxes incorrectly now the
there's a new report that's come out
could not determine conclusively whether
or not el me was Omar's brother why do
they even think that this guy el me was
Omar's brother because there are lots of
ties there are a lot of weird
connections between the two similarities
and names and also after Omar allegedly
disappeared he turns up working for and
with Omar's sister which would also be
his sister if they're brother and sister
which I think they probably are so and
you would think at least if Ilhan Omar
is looking for her long-lost ex-husband
and the guys working with her sister you
think the sister might tell it right
don't you think that's something that
would come up at family dinners probably
the whole thing stinks to high heaven
it's beyond stinking to high heaven
we know that she's committed crimes she
almost certainly committed immigration
fraud is the mainstream media going to
look into this is they're trying their
best to deflect they're trying their
best not to follow up on this
information which conserved
have been pushing for a long time now
what you are going to see in the
reaction to this is that any attack on
Ilhan Omar is motivated by bigotry it's
motivated because we don't like Muslims
we don't like immigrants we don't like
foreigners they're gonna say focus on
her policies woo okay we focus on her
policies and then they say that were the
excuse us of the same things when we say
that it's wrong of her to pray that all
awakens people up to the evil doings of
Israel that's that's policy we're saying
your policy toward Israel is really
weird and obviously brings up a lot of
questions about your motivations and
they say that's Islamophobia okay we
won't talk about your policy we'll talk
about your personal life you clearly
committed tax fraud and immigration
fraud they say stop talking about that
talk about the policy you're not allowed
to attack Ilhan Omar for any reason this
chick is bad news for the Democratic
Party and we're gonna see in 2020 and
maybe 2022 the referendums on these
people because these are the young guns
of the Democrats these are the fresh new
faces they get all the airtime Nancy
Pelosi never gets airtime but Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes Rashida Talib and Ilhan
Omar get all of the air time and she's
causing all of them are causing a lot of
headaches for the Democratic Party if
the Democrats primary them in 2020 if
they throw them out if they defund them
if they redistricting and get rid of
their districts then we will see that
the Democratic Party is serious about
kicking out these these radicals who are
causing so much trouble if they can't if
they can't manage to primary kick out
rhe district these people all of whom
are personally totally deficient
candidates who are totally compromised
some of whom have committed crimes if
they can't do that then we know for
certain this is their party now this is
Ilhan Omar's party this is Rashidah two
leaves for tea
this is Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's party
that that when the DNC chairman Tom
Perez said that AOC is the future of the
party he was right Pelosi lost control
clinton's lost control all of these
presidential candidates have lost
control that is what it's going to tell
us you almost could not possibly come up
with a worse story for a member
of Congress committed all of these
crimes major crimes if we can't hold
them accountable for this we are in much
worse shape than we thought that we were
speaking of weird sexual relations how's
that for a segue from Ilhan Omar's
brother to pedophilia there is now it's
actually a year old story but it's just
making the rounds now there is a TEDx
talk going around that proved something
that conservatives have been saying for
a long time we've said as a result of
the sexual revolution as a result of
normalizing all sorts of weird sexual
preferences as a result of saying that
you can't hold any view of sexual
morality that doesn't affirm everybody's
desires love is love or if it feels good
do it as a result of this the logical
conclusion is we're going to normalize
pedophilia people were born that way
they can't change their sexual
orientation we need patients we need to
bring it under the umbrella of all the
other sexual preferences we've been
saying that and the left has been
calling us crazy
now TEDx is hosting a talk on this exact
point Miriam Haines a medical student
from Germany is presenting her
controversial paper on the subject of
quote why our perception of pedophilia
has to change give it a listen according
to current research pedophilia is an
unchangeable sexual orientation just
like for example heterosexuality no one
chooses to be a pedophile no one can
cease being one the difference between
pedophilia and other sexual orientations
is that living out this sexual
orientation will end in a disaster right
now most of us feel discomfort when we
think about the scenario and most of us
feel discomfort when we think about
pedophiles but just like pedophiles we
are not responsible for our feelings we
do not choose them but we are
responsible for our actions
and we must make a decision
it is an our responsibility to reflect
and to overcome our negative feelings
about pedophiles and to treat them with
the same respect we treat other people
with we should accept that pedophiles
are people who have not chosen their
sexuality and who unlike most of us will
never be able to live it out freely if
they want to lead an upright life we
have to overcome our negative feelings
toward pedophiles I will say if I had to
cast anybody in the world to present the
argument for normalizing pedophilia I
would normalize that woman who sounds
exactly like a Bond villain satisfy Mr
Bond he must accept surrender FIRREA and
the abuse of children falls in Neuville
daughter Mr Bond this a beautiful accent
thank you for having that Miriam her
argument if you begin with the premises
that the Cultural Revolution the sexual
revolution that the left has embraced if
you begin with those premises that we
can't judge sexual orientation and
sexual Prem sexual preferences that
there is no normative good and normative
bad when it comes to sexual preference
if you begin with that preference of
that premise her argument is exactly
correct
pedophiles as far as we can tell are
born that way they don't choose to be
attracted to children who would choose
to be attracted to children nobody it's
a horrible life right it puts you at
risk of committing a lot of crimes it's
socially isolates you it makes you in
almost all cases incapable of sexual
gratification or fulfillment if consent
is the big issue then why on earth would
we judge pedophiles I mean do you even
hear this consent language at the very
end he or she says pedophiles will never
be able to act on their sexual urges if
they want to lead an upright life what
if they don't want to lead an upright
life then they can act on it no we have
laws against that we must have laws
against that this is sexual autonomy
taken to its logical conclusion and it's
funny that this is making the rounds
again during Pride Month which
celebrates not just homosexuality not
bisexuality not anything like that
sexually it celebrates all sorts of
sexuality and asexuality and no
sexuality and everything the premise
being you cannot judge somebody's sexual
preferences is good or bad and that
includes pedophiles the only alternative
to this conclusion is of course you can
judge sexual preferences of course it's
the alternative to pride which is shame
everybody has some weird sexual
preferences and you can either say that
those preferences are wrong in and of
themselves like pedophilia or you can
say they're no sexual preference can be
right or wrong because take child abuse
out of it we're just talking about the
preferences and I bet if you talk to a
lot of leftists today and you said hey
let's say there's a pedophile he's never
abused a child he's he's never going to
abuse a child but he is really attracted
to children and he doesn't even download
child pornography he just has an artist
just an artist draw him child
pornography so no children or even hurt
in the production of it should the
pedophile be allowed to look at drawn
images of children having sex or being
sexually abused let's say there are sex
robots now should the pedophile be
allowed to have sex with a sex robot
that looks like a child if he's never
going to abuse an actual child and if
you ask the left that question their gut
reaction would say of course not of
course he shouldn't be allowed to do
that but the logical end of their
arguments I think would say yeah of
course he should doesn't hurt anybody
he's indulging his own fantasies that's
fine are we going to indulge these sorts
of preferences in these sorts of
fantasies or not are we allowed to have
a more sophisticated discourse about
sexual morality and say well this is bad
maybe this isn't so bad it's not great
this is a little weird maybe you
shouldn't do that are we allowed to have
the discussions we've had about sexual
morality for all of human history or are
we in a world in which you are called a
bigot if you raise objections Eve
to a pedophile orientation that's the
question we're having and I think the
culture is clearly moving in the
direction of this Bond villain from
Germany before we go I got to talk about
Pete Buda jej Budaj edge is losing his
luster he's facing bado syndrome the
media embraced him they loved to me was
the next big thing now reality is
swinging back around he was at a town
hall and his constituents in South Bend
Indiana don't like to be spending all
his time running for president you hear
that person yelling you're gonna go back
to South Carolina like you were there
yesterday and they said one more
question for mayor Pete mayor Pete
doesn't have a word to say so he's
getting hit for being on the road too
much not doing his job in South Bend
he's also getting hit with black lives
matter accusations so there was a fatal
police shooting last week of a man named
Eric J Logan a 54 year old black man he
was killed by a cop the cop said he had
a knife on him we don't know if he had a
knife on him or not
the reason it's suspect is the body
camera was off and there were no
witnesses to the cop shooting this guy
also there are allegations already
recorded of this guy's fellow cops
saying that the cop had been making
racist comments in the past so South
Bend residents are angry about this
especially black residents and mayor
Pete doesn't know how to answer the
anger
[Music]
[Music]
brutal so obviously there's no evidence
that Peabody jej is some sort of racial
bigot and obviously this shooting is not
Pete Buddha judge's fault the shooting
is compounded by the fact that Buddha
jej wasn't there on the job because he's
running for president so that does hurt
it also shows a weakness in his campaign
he's not woken up he thought that by
playing up the gay card he could get rid
of all of his other issues his all of
his other privileges he's a white
Harvard grad road Scholar former analyst
for an elite consulting firm McKinsey
who looks like Alfred E Newman this guy
is the picture of privilege and he's
pretending that because he's sexually
attracted to men this cancels that out
and he's woke he isn't woke enough and I
never thought he was woken up and
they've been asking this question about
him on the left for a while this also
shows an important rule in politics if
you live by contrivance you will die by
contrivance Pete Budaj edge is a totally
contrived candidate who is totally being
propped up by the left-wing elite media
black lives matter to is not exactly a
grassroots movement it has been propped
up artificially by the media by people
who were run major activists in the
Democratic Party and one contrivance is
about to take down another contrivance
that is bad news for Pete Budaj edge and
more bad news for Pete muda judge
Elizabeth Warren is surging lieth is
coming out she's embracing her wolken
as' she's going all the way in she's
gunning to win that progressive vote
which led to the most ridiculous line
that I have heard in politics in at
least three or four days
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know if you could hear that
she said what better place to spend my
birthday than right here at Planned
Parenthood which is it's pretty dark I
don't want to laugh at it what better
place to spend your birthday than at
Planned Parenthood any other place
Planned Parenthood is the worst place on
planet Earth to spend your birthday the
entire purpose of Planned Parenthood is
to prevent birthdays but that's
absurdity that's the absurdity of
left-wing politics and Liz Warren looks
like she is surging for the mantle of it
bad news for Budaj
good news for her the absurdity is only
going to get worse as we look forward to
the first Democratic presidential
primary debate coming up in just a
matter of days can't wait for it in the
meantime I'm Michael Nolt this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show
representative Ilhan Omar is accused now
of marrying her brother in order to
skirt our immigration laws a very
bizarre weird situation but if it's true
she committed a serious crime is it true
though
well well we'll take a look at the
evidence and you decide also speaking of
looking at evidence president Trump is
accused again of sexual assault there
are a lot of things about this latest
accusation that give me pause cause me
to be skeptical but we'll look at the
specifics there look at the evidence or
lack thereof today on the Matt Walsh
show